[Music]
we are pleased to present to you
the online islamic school for your
children your majesty is a unique online
learning platform
with an islamic curriculum approved by
scholars in medina your majesty is
inspired by the hadith of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam who said
that when the son of adam passes away
all of his actions come to an end except
for free
ongoing charity beneficial knowledge and
a righteous child who makes dua for them
your majesty encompasses all three of
these
so you and your children can benefit in
this world and the hereafter
why choose your majesty online examine
school providing complete islamic
education
authentic knowledge based on the quran
and sunnah
live and animated lessons teaching islam
in a fun and engaging way
e-learning track progress watch and
pause lessons ask questions and more
utilizing the latest technology we use a
combination of live lessons
and professionally created animated
classes so that your majestic students
can learn using a variety of methods
lessons take place three days a week but
are recorded so children can catch up in
their own time and learn at their own
pace
although your medicine follows the
academic calendar children can enroll at
any time
we have created a bespoke e-learning
platform to enhance your children's
learning
each student has their own customizable
portal containing numerous features such
as
the ability to pause watch and re-watch
lessons
track how much of the course they have
completed view their quiz and exam
results
check their quran and do our progress
and ask questions at any time
children are awarded badges for their
progress there are regular competitions
and exams with certificates upon
completion
we have built an easy to use system
simplified for children your magista
works on all devices
including laptops tablets and mobile so
children can learn anywhere
at any time on any device your children
will learn
quran and tafsir
[Music]
hadith
there will also be regular live classes
for the entire family
where your children's islamic questions
will be answered your majesty is not
just for those who have children
it's for everyone who wants to inspire a
child and share in the reward of them
seeking knowledge
you can sponsor a child who cannot
afford to enroll using our sponsor a
child option
during our journey in parenthood and
seeking knowledge in medina
we spent six years developing your
medicine with hundreds of hours spent
researching preparing teaching and
creating high quality videos
we are unique because we teach authentic
islamic knowledge in a fun and engaging
way
we truly believe nothing like your
majesty exists your majesty
founded the prophet city inspired by the
prophet sunnah
from our majesty enroll your child today